the minions are cute they can sing they
can dance and they are absolutely
fearless
this might seem like a completely crazy
idea but have you ever imagined what
Disney Princesses would look like if
they were minions Jasmine as a minion
will make you laugh out loud don't
forget to subscribe to our Channel and
give this video a big thumbs up today
we're showing you 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined as minions Pocahontas the
first princess to get the honor of being
transformed into a minion is Pocahontas
this image was created by Gen Louis one
of the BuzzFeed staff Pocahontas is one
of the most selfless Disney Princesses
with a heart full of love what could she
possibly have in common with minions
sure she's free spirited and very
adventurous but when Pocahontas as a
minion even be able to survive
Pocahontas a story with her feminine
look it's hard to believe Pocahontas and
the minions would make a good pair but
we're really digging this now this would
make a very interesting turn on the
Pocahontas movie wouldn't it she's still
wearing her wonderful native dress but
instead of her usual self she has a body
of a minion complete with gloves and
yellow minion skin what do you think is
this a good look for Pocahontas or
should she just stick to her old self
this polka minion looks a little bit
scared and definitely not ready for the
world she'll have to face as a short
yellow looking thing that only talks
gibberish just imagine John Smith ever
seen this version of Pocahontas this
minion is clearly not having any of it
and probably just wants to go home to
his crew Merida despite their antics the
minions are quite independent much like
everyone's favorite princess who might
just be the most skilful Disney
character when it comes to archery have
you guessed which Disney princess we're
talking about it's everyone's favorite
main character from the much beloved
movie brave Merida as the minion might
seem like a hard thing to imagine
because her hair is probably longer than
the actual minions themselves but the
talented Chris kakazu Darrin somehow
managed to make it all possible
we loved the added curly hair and we bet
this minion probably prefers the
to the hair they have but giving a
minion a bow and arrow wouldn't really
turn out to be that beneficial unless
they also take Merida's amazing archery
skills the minions might not have
anything in common with Merida except
for their bravery and their unapologetic
way of being different Merida is much
more outspoken but the minions are
absolutely fearless and never give a
second thought to their ideas do you see
a minion being able to take over merit a
story and brave they might work better
as her little brothers but hey who knows
maybe the minions do have a couple of
hidden talents we are not really aware
of Snow White we hope you're sitting
down and are ready for the world of
laughs with these next pictures because
we can barely hold ourselves together
just imagine Snow White as a minion what
would that even look like well according
to Gen Lewis this is what it looks like
we have to say we're kind of lost for
words on this one and we can't decide
whether we really love it or we really
hate it we'll let you decide for us let
us know in the comments what you think
the only thing Snow White and minions
have in common are their unique voices
although not similar at all
each of them is unique in their own way
we also think Snow White would actually
get along quite nicely with the minions
since she gets along with practically
everyone but Snow White looking like a
minion now this is a laugh we've been
waiting for just check out that minion
he can't stop smiling which minion do
you think this is based on his hair we
believe it's Bob which would explain his
crazy smiling personality while Snow
White's hand is in the somewhat graceful
position this minion completely missed
the memo on how to pose to fit in with
the beautiful Disney Princess something
tells us that an apple wouldn't be the
main fruit in the movie if the minions
took over Tiana
come on you have to admit that imagining
Tiana as the minion is just a little bit
funny
she's perhaps one of the most underrated
Disney Princesses with the strongest
work ethic she knows exactly what she
wants but she also knows she has to work
hard to get it those are some true
Disney princes personality goals right
there and we didn't even see her
living her life as a true princess but
thanks to Jim Lewis from BuzzFeed we can
see her as a minion what do you think of
this picture yay or nay
we believe this minions name is Kevin
judging by his hair we're not quite sure
what happened to his lips but we love
that he's still wearing Tiana's princess
dress on the other hand
Tiana's totally not having any of this
do you think tiana would be able to
handle minions better yet what would the
minions do if they had to run a
restaurant as Tiana does we have no
problem seeing minions interact with a
frog so perhaps this might still be a
very interesting mix we still can't get
over those lips though and not to
mention the somewhat flirty eyes Kevin's
giving and of course Tiana's dress the
internet really is a very strange but at
the same time wonderful place isn't it
Elsa watch out Elsa reimagined as a
minion is just way too sassy for us to
handle this minion fits perfectly with
the frozen queen of arendelle and he's
definitely ready to sing let it go as
loud as he can although we feel like let
it go might be replaced with let it
banana based on how much the minions
love their bananas and potatoes what do
you think oh yay oh ma this awesome
illustration was created by a very
talented artist named Chris K Asif Jaron
Chris Cassidy Aaron who is known for
creating outstanding cartoon character
related artwork so there's absolutely no
surprise that his version of Elsa
reimagined as a minion would come out
looking like this
this sure is one incredibly sassy and
fierce minion freezing things like
nobody's business
the minions might actually be familiar
with this power because their boss GRU
uses a similar thing but we do think
that the minions would probably take
Elsa's power in a completely different
way freezing bananas perhaps
accidentally freezing other minions
doing something with the power that was
somehow managed to shut down the entire
world now that's a plot story we'd love
to see in a movie but only under the
condition if the minions can be dressed
as Elsa because this looks absolutely
incredible Cinderella
but wait we're not done yet the minion
party's just getting started and with
this Disney Princess it'll be in full
swing let's look how Cinderella would
look as a minion we can imagine gen
Lewis must have been laughing so hard
when she made these the minions and
Cinderella do have one thing in common
they all have very dainty feet and in
their own language they could probably
even say bibbidi-bobbidi-boo although it
might not have the same effect as it
does when the fairy godmother says it
they probably even call her cinderelly
who knows maybe this idea isn't that bad
after all but it sure looks funny we
believe this minion might be Kevin or
Tim and he's definitely loving it
doesn't he look hilarious wait love how
the minion is still wearing the
princess's gloves instead of his own but
the dainty feet might be the only thing
minions might have in common with
Cinderella the princess is just as
hard-working as Tiana she always is
optimistic and kind regardless of what
happens to her and minions well they're
just minions there's no better word to
describe them just wait until you see
who's next want to guess she's friends
Belle we're not quite sure what language
would Belle speak as a minion imagine
the minions singing tale as old as time
we're sure it would make a very amusing
Beauty and the Beast well this is what
Belle would look like as a minion
according to Gen Lewis we're sure this
minion al wouldn't have a neck that
looks like a triangle but let's roll
with it by the looks of it this minions
name is Carl he's the small one-eyed one
who always seems to get in the most
trouble but look how fascinated he is by
being able to look like Belle or perhaps
it's because he's looking at the
enchanted Rose come to think of it cos
personality might fit in perfectly with
Belle's outspoken Stern and curious
except that Belle probably reads a bit
more than your average minion would what
do you think of this odd pairing we love
Carl's face he just looks so happy with
minions crazy ways we wonder who would
be the Beast in this version of beauty
the beasts do you think miss Potts
Cogsworth Lumiere and everyone else
would also transform into minions or
would they keep their looks Ariel
although jasmine is one of our favorite
princesses reimagined as a minion from
the list
Ariel might come a close second if you
love the Little Mermaid but you also
like Despicable Me this might just seem
like the perfect combination edited by
John Lewis this aerial reimagined as a
minion is definitely special in the
original movie this is where Ariel
finishes her part of your world song
after she rescues Erik from the storm
now just try to reimagine what that
scene would look like if Ariel were a
minion if Carl looked funny to you on
Belle you must be cracking up at this
site this is a minion dressed as Ariel
complete with the black gloves it's
still wearing Ariel's shell bathing suit
come to think of it flounder has the
exact same yellow color as minions do so
perhaps this could work
however the question on our minds is can
minions actually swim and sing
underwater at the same time yes they
probably can did you know that minions
actually were developed underwater
some people think that their safety
goggles are full of water and act as a
visual aid because of the different
visual requirements they might face on
land Disney we have a wish make a new
little mermaid and put the minions in it
Aurora ever wonder if there are any
similarities between Aurora and the
minions we did some digging and here's
what we found out the minions are cute
Aurora is cute the Sleeping Beauty was
inspired by Tchaikovsky's ballet show
under the same name and the minions were
also seen doing some ballet Aurora has
the fewest lines of any Disney character
and many of the despicable Me characters
don't really say much call us crazy but
we do see some similarities between the
two popular characters we are absolutely
loving this Aurora reimagined as a
minion this design was done by Chris
Cassidy Erin and it
just incredible the minions have cute
big eyes which makes their Aurora
cosplay even cuter with the long hair
and the pink outfit it's all just
perfect
Aurora's look was based on Audrey
Hepburn but perhaps Disney should really
consider using the minions as an
inspiration for the next Sleeping Beauty
movie because this really looks
absolutely hilarious the minions often
dress up so putting them in a sleeping
beauty outfit doesn't look like anything
out of the ordinary what do you think of
this pairing is this a yay or nay we're
starting to think these yellow creatures
would make really good cosplayers
Jasmine you might have giggle that's no
right as a minion or totally laughed at
Belle as a minion but get ready because
you're about to see when Jasmine would
look like if she had a yellow face
goggles black gloves and a flirty book
me Jasmine reimagined as a minion made
by Gen Lewis this picture is definitely
our favorite and we're not even sure why
perhaps it's because it actually looks
pretty good maybe we've been staring at
minions dressed as Disney Princesses for
a bit too long but this is the best
picture we've ever seen we believe this
little guy's name is Dave he's the one
with nicely combed hair but his hair is
nothing compared to Jasmine's we love
his pose the black gloves and the fact
that the artist still kept Jasmine's
light blue outfit does it fit perfectly
the original jasmine was so beautiful
the artist actually had to rework
Aladdin into something more presentable
but if the minions ever had the chance
of playing Jasmine in Aladdin perhaps we
would be able to see what the Prince
would look like originally it really
brings a whole new world as jasmine and
Aladdin would say don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up and click that
subscribe button which is your favorite
minion moment let us know in the
comments below for more crazy disney
videos check out 10 disney princesses
reimagined as teenagers see you in the
next video
[Music]